acerca de la exactitud de los recuerdos
qué sabemos que son ciertos.
Hay décadas de investigación,
ejemplos y ejemplos de casos como éste,
donde los individuos
realmente creen. Ninguno de esos adolescentes
que lo identificó
pensaban que señalaban a la persona equivocada.
Ninguno de ellos pensó que no podía ver la cara de la persona.
Todos tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos.
Todos nuestros recuerdos son recuerdos reconstruidos.
Son el producto de lo que originalmente hemos vivido
y de todo lo que pasó después.
Son dinámicos.
Son maleables. Son volátiles,
y como resultado de ello, todos tenemos que recordar ser cautelosos,
que la precisión de nuestros recuerdos
no se mide en la forma en que están vivos
ni en la certeza que tenemos de que son correctos.
Gracias. (Aplausos)